claire n'est pas nucléaire je ne sais
pas mais en tout cas si on fait pour
produire de l'électricité de manière
voilà écologique
je suis favorable le nucléaire ça
m'inspire pas beaucoup pour ma part j'ai
l'impression que c'est quand même pas ça
peut être assez dangereux et il ya des
déchets forcément j'imagine donc je
n'approuve pas si on veut se mettre à
voir tout ce qui fonctionne et les
criques des voitures des a continué à
consommer l'électricité comme on le fait
faut bien le produire quoi donc le jour
on a dû le jour on arrive à avoir des
trucs profs qui marche je dis pas mais
pour l'instant j'ai pas l'impression
qu'il est temps de passer à autre chose
à voir de chevalier des temps de faire
attention à ce qu'on m'utilise comme
énergie comment on le fait favorables et
défavorables qu'est-ce qu'on fait où on
va je crois qu'il faut vraiment bien
réfléchir aux conséquences
parce que là il ya beaucoup de choses
qui passent à côté et il est grand temps
d'ouvrir les yeux et qu' il y ait des
gens posent et qui réfléchissent mais
dans un objectif pour l'humanité et pas
pour la destruction peut pas être
favorable quelque chose qui est
dangereux comme ça par contre ils
favoris cités déjà si les maisons
étaient équipés de panneaux solaires ça
pourrait énormément aidé et on peut
individualisé aussi l'électricité chacun
enfin notamment à la campagne après on
vide c'est quand même une autre
oui je favorable au nucléaire parce que
tant qu'on n'a pas de deux meilleurs
temps qu'on n'a pas de meilleure
solution pour faire de l'électricité
propre
je vois pas on va faire revenir les
centrales à charbon donc voila l
problème des lieux clair si ça pète on
est dans la merde
au japon on a vu le tout que ça à faire
sebbar laisse quand même quand ça pète
on sait pas ce que va devenir